did you know today is justin fields
second pro day you know i wouldn't have
known that if i hadn't checked twitter
this morning and saw a five-word tweet
that today is justin field's second
product i really do appreciate that
because those of us who followed the
sport actively wouldn't have otherwise
known but it is today in columbus
star-studded cast of teams there people
either seriously interested in fields or
seriously interested in setting up a
smoke screen
in or or also also possibly you know
because the falcons are going to be
there and i've said this time and again
right haven't said it yet this year if
you're thinking about trading that pick
you got to do the full work up on the
player so you know what the player's
worth in trade so you can converse
intelligently with the team that wants
to come get him
and and i think that's part of it too
even if you don't want the guy you got
to know enough about the guy to maximize
the value you get for that pick because
they're not coming up to get the fourth
pick or the fifth pick coming up
the bengals probably won't send someone
on the 90-minute drive uh because
they're probably not going to trade out
of their spot but for the falcons yeah
we got to know what that player's worth
so i expect a lot of people to be at
this thing today yeah i mean the falcons
are sitting in that prime spot at number
four
you know i think if you know again if
you're any team that's even thinking
quarterback in the top 15 right now i
think you got to be there in that
convert top 20 whatever
first round
you you need to be there for that you
just don't know how this is going to
shake out at the quarterback position
yet you know again yeah i think it's mac
jones with the 49ers but i don't think
it's written in stone you know it seems
like atlanta is still not sure what
they're going to do
right and you know added to that
you know with with guys like trey lands
and justin fields you know there's some
rawness to their game this workout's
important
we got to see you know can they did they
fix some of the things we didn't like in
the first workout you know okay here's
another workout can they just like cut
it loose to another degree
and show that they're able to do some of
the you know finer things as far as from
within the pocket you know that people
question justin fields about a little
bit you know the elongated throwing
motion and all the space he needs and
all of those type of things so i think
it's interesting in that we got teams
that need quarterbacks and i think it's
a group of quarterbacks that
people like they like their high talent
but you know there's some questions
especially when it comes to mac jones
treylands or justin fields about how
people totally feel about those three
guys especially
there is a line though for a team like
the 49ers
between
being decisive and having a plan and
doing your due diligence once you've
moved from 12 to three and remember
whoever they pick in that spot they will
have given up three first round picks
and a third round pick so it's one thing
to do your due diligence it's another
thing to create the impression that you
really don't know what you're going to
do we'll figure it out later we're
making this big move
not for a player but for the spot yeah
and we'll figure out which of the three
quarterbacks who are left over that we
want you i don't i and i understand
there's value in building the mystery
because we're talking about the 49ers
you're getting a lot of free publicity
if you don't think that's part of the
business you aren't paying attention to
the business but you don't want to come
off as wishy-washy or you don't want to
come off as a team that just that just
had an impulse buy right right and
and decided yeah hey we're going to buy
an expensive car we're going to we're
going to pay for the car well which car
you're going to get well that's a good
question we'll figure that out later
yeah you don't want that to be the
impression agreed agreed there i i think
there is some negative aspects to doing
that um
and you know again i don't think this
move was made by like you know
just
emotions or hey i want this spot and
we'll figure it out as we go along no i
would think that shanahan lynch the
49ers have their eye on one particular
guy you know and that that is their guy
but they're gonna do everything they
need to do here to check all the boxes
and make sure they feel a hundred
percent confident in that and that their
you know total thoughts or moving up to
the number three spot have been
justified by all the things they've seen
and done and meeting with the guys and
all that i think that's more of what it
is i would think they have a pretty good
clue of who they're going to take but
they're just doing their homework and
making sure you know all the uh t's are
crossed and dotted eyes and all that
crap
and let me see one last thing before we
move on because i think pete would
prefer that we actually get to the
things we're supposed to be talking
about that's a good talk
as the draft approaches
remember this one point and this is the
kind of thing that will anger others in
the business but my obligation is to you
not you chris but you the audience
be extra discerning
of reports from reporters who work for
networks that will televise the draft
that would be aimed at creating more
uncertainty and greater mystery because
they have an incentive to maximize
audience so if someone from nfl network
knows that it's mac jones at number
three or if someone from espn knows it's
mac jones at number three or that it's
not mac jones at number three they're
not going to tell you in no uncertain
terms because we are now in that bubble
we're now in that zone where thou shalt
say nothing that would tend to diminish
or dilute in any way the audience that
we are trying to gather when the draft
begins that's the truth folks we can
either dabble in the truth or we can
participate in the charade the truth is
you're going to be getting some bs over
the next couple of weeks and you've
already been getting some of it because
they want to maximize the eyeballs and
there's a point where the truth has to
take a back seat to that we know that we
know that directly on draft night
because nobody's allowed to to tip the
picks and everybody knows who wants to
know the picks because you get a backlog
of five of them as they're trying to
produce this tv show but beyond what
happens on draft night we're in the zone
now we're 15 days away just just be
advised that you may be getting played
in order to have more interest when
draft night rolls around i mean yeah
a lot of us are going to watch it anyway
but to the extent there's somebody who's
on the fence who really doesn't know
what the first four picks are going to
be they're going to tune in yeah agreed
mike i mean you know this is it's
propaganda time you got to be careful
about who you listen to what you listen
to what it's about you know yeah there's
people that got needs and they're trying
to push their narratives to of course
push money into their pocket and
that's the way this business goes so you
do you got to be careful about what you
hear and who you take information from
at this time of the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports